foreign
[Music]
side by side ATV
and they crashed and I'm a volunteer
firefighter and I responded thank God no
yo yo what's up this is John the Dr John
deloney show
greatest mental health and wellness in
marriage and parenting whatever podcast
ever made
so glad that you joined us
wow so glad that you're with us give us
your most precious resource your time if
you want to be on this show give us a
buzz at
1-844-693-3291-1844-693-3291 we got a
pack show so I'm just gonna go straight
to the phones today let's go to uh Chris
in Fargo North Dakota what's up brother
Chris
I'm all right my man how are we doing
this morning
[Music]
you're good man you're good
I got nothing but time my man
okay what's up
actually do this for me take a take as
deep a breath as you can and hold it
and let it out
and those shoulders your shoulders wrap
around your ear drop them as low as you
can okay
okay
cool and one more thing
take your hands and squeeze them
together as tight as you can
and count backwards squeeze them as
tight as you can five
four three
two
all right what's up man
I lost my son
about a month today I have to go
uh what was his name
Jesse
how old are you
12. oh my gosh
um
and I'm a volunteer firefighter
and I responded saying God no really
dude I'm so sorry
I'm sorry across the board I'm sorry a
thousand different ways man
foreign
I have a 12 year old little boy
and I've
my my guts just left my body
as you said that I'm sorry man
so I'm guessing if you responded then
um
was it an emergency was there an
accident what happened
yeah he was
at the neighbor's house
and a friend of the neighbor was taking
him to pick up
his daughter
and
I wasn't there my wife was there and she
didn't know he had been drinking that
much and they were on a side by side ADV
antage crashed
gosh
Chris I'm so sorry man
tell me about Jesse
tall kid short kid fast short short kid
pudgy kid tell me about him felt skinny
I hear that's a skinny little guy small
one of the smallest kids in his class
yeah
funny kid loud annoying silly tell me
about him
this is funny to the point where he
thought he was funnier than he actually
was I thought he was
awesome
he got along with all the adults
everybody loved him yeah he
even talk about things that
like sign stuff to the adults and they
just
Blown Away by him oh he's brilliant huh
yes very smart
what did he love what did he love
he loved taking things apart
they drove me nuts
but what's the worst thing what's the
worst thing he ever took apart
we just buy him
we buy him something and then within
three days he would take it apart oh he
was that kid yeah yes
you get him like a VCR or something he
takes it not VCR because it's not the
20th century but yeah get him an Xbox
instead of playing it he takes it apart
see how it works wow yep exactly
so
you lost your son
you lost your life as you know it
everything's different now
and
my son lost a light in his life
because the Lights Went Out didn't it
like I'm saying like as another kid
who's 12 they were going to grow up and
create the new world together
and a light went out right
yep
so all the way across the country in
Nashville Tennessee I want you to know
my heart's broken with you and that
doesn't bring your kid back that doesn't
make you hurt less but I want you to
know you're not you're not heartbroken
alone
I'm so sorry man
and I'm sorry that you responded to that
I'm sorry that
that shouldn't have happened
procedurally that shouldn't have
happened
um that's probably just the kind of guy
you are though as you show up even when
they tell you don't come you show up and
well I didn't know what was going on oh
wow okay
I was home
before the call you know
we carry a pager and when the call comes
out we just go to the station yeah and I
had an idea it came out as a
personal injury accident
oh it didn't come out as a 1087
no yeah we don't use 10 codes no you
don't okay
and so I just
went to the station
I jumped on the front right see
went to the call I had an idea where it
was
and it didn't make sense I'm like that's
a side road that's
that's uh how is there an accident there
and we turned down the street it was
about three blocks away from my house
and
the driver said was that wasn't that
your wife
and I said I didn't see her and we get
closer to the scene and
I started to recognized
two of the people there
and
that's when I started to panic a little
bit because I knew what was going I knew
he was over at the neighbor's house and
there's my neighbor and one of his
friends
they heard the sirens they ran up there
so when did I pull up I see those two I
jump out
and I just kind of forgot everything
that it was supposed to do
and one of the guys grabbed me and
before I could get close to the scene
and just pulled me to the back of the
truck and sat me down
and then that's when the sheriff came
over and told me what happened
whoever that that partner was of yours
um did a heroic thing and I'm glad they
did that
it's amazing yeah that's an amazing man
right there
um
foreign
so how can I help you man I I want to
hug you you're not here you want to hug
you I'm trying to wipe in tears of my
own away here on the show and that
doesn't happen for me
um
I've shown up the scenes I don't know I
know that call
when your heart starts beating faster
because you think something's wrong and
then all sudden you know something's
wrong
um I've had to be that guy that pulled
the parent back and said you don't you
don't need that in your head
um
and I've had man all that whole thing
oh geez man even though I wasn't at I
didn't see him it doesn't matter I know
I know all right still get flashes of I
know I know I know
I know
can I tell you something that's gonna
sound crazy
sure
he's not hurting right now
so much of our head wants to go back to
that moment
he's not hurting right now he's at peace
right now
okay
and if there's if there's no other peace
in your heart right now
he's not scared anymore he's not hurting
anymore he's still
no okay sorry there's another thing that
he was
so I get the call
and I'll go up to my truck and I go up
to the
next street and I either take a right to
go to the fire station
or I go straight
and I just respond to the scene and I
listen to my procedures and I took that
right
I feel like I failed them twice
because I
as one as a father
because I don't
deal with that guy
and
I feel like I failed him as a
firefighter because I didn't go straight
and just be with him until he passed
away yeah
and if you've ever listened to heard a
word you come out of my mouth I'll tell
you your feelings are real and they're
very very important
and they serve a purpose
and our feelings lie to us
the very first way you explained what
happened the words out of your mouth
were I wasn't there
and I should have stopped you then I
didn't
there's no possible way that you would
think in your neighborhood
that a friend of yours would let your
kid get behind the wheel of an ATV with
a drunk driver
any any more likelihood that you're it
would be your fault if your kid got
struck by lightning
walking down the street
so I get the impulse to feel like I'm
dad I have one job that's to keep my kid
safe and I failed it I get that impulse
I have that same exact impulse
but you're gonna have to open your hands
on that one because that's not on you
okay it's on the heart of a guy who was
intoxicated and got behind the wheel of
a vehicle and invited a child along with
him
the other thing is I get the impulse as
a first responder
but that that moment of failure that's
not for him
you feel like you failed yourself
yeah and you didn't
and I also know I can tell you that over
and over and over and your body's going
to respond as your body's going to
respond okay it's going to take it's
going to take seasons for you to this to
pass
not to pass this won't the whole thing
won't pass you'll remember this for the
rest of your life it's now part of you
I'm saying you will come to peace with
the Fault part of this this is my fault
this is not my fault okay
you're a damn good firefighter
you signed up you volunteered for crying
out loud you didn't get paid for this
you do this because this is who you are
your community is better because you do
this
and the fantasy that if I just gone
straight I would have had one more
second I get that I get that and it's
not true
because that fantasy turns into and I
probably would have done the one thing
that fill in the blank right
thank you
so how can I help you now my guess is
you're in the black hole man the food
tastes food tastes different when you
even bother to eat love feels
everything's off
hey yeah it's slowly getting better
time back till my full-time job now
um
but you're just going through the
motions right
yes yeah yeah
yeah I that's completely 100 right
okay
um king of distractions now whatever I
can find to distract myself that's fine
um
I don't know I don't know
what to expect I don't know
I hate feeling this way but I also don't
want to give it up I know
because now your son's no longer in your
arms and he's transferred to your pain
and you think if you stop hurting
or if you smile a little bit or if you
have some joy that he's gonna go
or that somehow sharing a meal with your
wife
and y'all just exhaling for the first
time in a month and a half is somehow
dishonoring to him and it's not
life won't go on life is different now
things won't get back to the way they
were things are different now
there will be a creation of a new and it
will take a while
and so anybody telling you to rush this
process you need to cut them out of your
life
okay
you lost your heartbeat
right
well
I have another son
sir
all right oh yeah I lost one of my
heartbeats I have another son there you
go
and you're going to walk past that
bedroom and it's going to be empty and
your whole body is going to fall apart
and you're going to pull up to a pizza
place and you're going to say table for
four it's just going to pop out of your
mouth and then you're gonna break down
crying in a way that you
thought you'd cried all the tears you
got and nope I got more
all right
or someone's gonna be
trying to be kind and they're going to
say something that in your situation is
insensitive even though they're being
lovely how many kids you got
and your first impulse is going to be 2
and you're going to say one you're going
to say well I mean and then the whole
thing
right yes or did Yeah by all of a sudden
I just
I don't I don't know even know what to
expect anymore oh
certainly okay here's what I'm gonna do
right you're not gonna remember a lot of
this
um I'm gonna give you four or five
things okay
and we will cut this out and we'll send
it to you before it's even edited and
all that kind of you know glossed over
and mastered or whatever they do to it
to make it pretty just so you have these
things now you don't have to wait
another month for it to come out okay
okay
here's thing number one
you cannot do this by yourself
I don't care how tough you are I don't
care how you know Fargo you are I don't
care how firemen you are you gotta have
other people you gotta have other people
that you say I'm not doing okay today
today's a today's a black hole day
and they're not going to try to fix you
they're going to hug you they're gonna
go get coffee they're going to show up
with a donut or they're going to show up
with some dinner and they're not going
to say much and just gonna sit on your
porch with you do you have that
yes I am okay yes
your only job
is to not isolate let them be the rest
okay
you might tell them here's what I need
if I call you you five guys if I call
you here's what I'm looking for
I'm looking for you just to say that
sucks I'm heartbroken
I'm looking for you to send me a picture
of my son that you might have on your
phone I'm looking for you just
said come over and with some tacos
okay
that's number one number two
grief is like a fingerprint it's
different for every single person
and yours is going to be different than
your wives and this is why many many
couples who experience what you've
experienced don't make it
because they start holding each other to
Impossible standards and they're so mad
and so angry and so frustrated and so
heartbroken that they just lash out at
the closest person to him that happens
to be their wife or their husband
or they say things like I can't believe
you're already back at work how can you
even breathe I can't believe you went to
the gym
I can't even get out of bed
and so I want you and your wife
to commit to having regular probably
every other day check in with one
another
and a whole lot of Grace
because you're gonna have good days and
bad days on different days
and one of you is going to have a bad
day and the other person is going to be
having a good day
and the person who's having a bad day
has to have the courage and The Bravery
to say go have your good day
because bring in another bring in
somebody from their good day down to
your bad day doesn't make your bad day
better
okay
but you and your wife are gonna have to
create a new language that you did not
have before
okay
yeah and you're gonna have to decide we
need to learn Spanish because we got to
learn a different way to talk because we
can't talk English anymore in this house
that's that's where you got to look at
it okay
you have to remember to do the basic
life things like eat and move
and turn your screens off
okay
yeah
and you're gonna have to learn this is
the hard one you're gonna have to sleep
and you've if you've ever listened to
this show you know how against sleep
meds I am I'm okay in a season
okay yeah
the doctor prescribed me something I'm
trying to get off of okay and just go to
melatonin right now okay I um I I have
I've never talked about this publicly
but we're in it now
um
I will send you personally
um a I've got a a substantial discount
code with the only supplement company
that I use they're called Thorn and they
are pharmaceutical grade they're the
best of the best of the best and I've
got a significant discount code that
I'll send you and I'll send you the
personal sleep stuff that I use from
them
okay they're just a supplement it's not
a it's not a narcotic or anything like
that
um it's what I use and everybody's got a
little bit of a tinkering difference
whether it's Farm Gaba 250 or whether
it's ISO or whatever the thing is right
um but getting some supplement help for
sleep is is wise right now
okay having some sort of I'm going for a
walk having some sort of I'm gonna go
exercise having some sort of something
and you may go to the gym
and then just turn on and go home
because it's not happening that day
that's okay
all right
[Music]
don't here's the other one do not over
compensate with your child with your
other son
okay okay let your other son's gonna
have his own unique grief
the last thing we want to do is have him
feel like he's responsible for making
sure Mom and Dad's okay
yeah he gets to be in a few comments he
gets to be a little boy
right
and he's also going to say things like I
feel like all you talk about is Jesse
that's fine how old is he
he's 15. exactly he's 15.
right there's a reason we don't let him
drive yet
so he's gonna have his comments and
that's all fine and good his life
everything about his life is different
now
okay
here's the last one in this one's heart
this one's real hard
how long have you been doing a volunteer
fire department stuff
about 15 years though okay
so I'm talking to
um somebody who's responded and seen
their fair share of stuff right
I've been pretty fortunate but yeah okay
I've been doing a couple calls I've been
doing a couple calls
yeah I have two and here's what I can't
do like when I I call it the lightning
bolt when the lightning bolt pops into
my head out of nowhere
of some guy who shot and killed himself
and this is disaster
or some car wreck scene that I showed up
to some sort of something the lightning
bolt pops into my head and the moment
that lightning bolt pops into my head
with that picture or that thought
I have a choice
am I going to meditate on that picture
and go down that rabbit hole and my
heart rate will get up and my body will
flood itself with cortisol and
adrenaline just like I was back on that
scene in real time
and I'll start thinking about it and
I'll think about what I said and what I
could have said and what I should have
said and I can't believe I did this and
that one guy that took a swing at me
because I was telling him that his wife
had like all those things
I can do that
and when I do that I'm choosing two
things to be more miserable and to
dishonor the person who passed away
here's the other thing I can do
when that lightning bolt pops into my
head which I cannot control
it just does I don't understand it it
happens in the shower it happens at
church it happens all kind of random
places that you'll just think of a thing
I can hold my breath for two to four
seconds
I can exhale
and I can intentionally put another
picture in my head
in your case one of walking into a room
and seeing the brand new Xbox you just
bought Jesse all taken apart
or the time he made y'all laugh at
dinner and you were laughing so hard you
were crying
or a moment like I'm at uh like a moment
I had a night ago when my 12 year old
walked through the room and said
something and walked into the other room
and I thought to myself I didn't know I
could love like that
you get to replace that scene
you get to replace that little picture
you have in your head of just his shoe
of all the people crowding around
all the lights you get to replace those
pictures him in the casket
you get to replace all those pictures
with something beautiful
with something of a memory of his memory
of joy and here's what will happen
those flashes those lightning bolts
that's your brain trying to remind you
that there's scary crap out there you
don't need that reminder it's just your
brain trying to take care of you okay
okay what we're going to do over time is
we're going to shift our default
settings so that when we think of Jesse
we smile first
we don't instantly get transported back
to the worst possible moment of our
entire lives
it's a but listen it's a practice you
gotta practice and you're going to find
yourself 15 minutes into a thought
exercise and you're gonna have to call
yourself out on it I will yell in my
home
no stop
I will do all sorts of wild things to
stop those tracks as they get going
and I've never lived what you've lived
through
the pool will be magnetic
and here's one more final final thing
your son is not in your pain
okay he's in your heart he's in your
hearts he's in those kids in the class
that he was friends with
he was in
the bodies and minds and spirits of
those he made to laugh like crazy
he's there man
he's not in your home where he should be
and he's not in his bed where he should
be
but he's not hurting anymore either
do you believe me
yeah okay
anytime you ask yourself what should I
do now
just be right where you're at
there's not a Playbook moving forward
man other than take care of yourself
be with people love your wife love your
other son
okay
all right
um
there will come a season when you make
meaning of this okay there'll come a
season when you're now what
I'm gonna start speaking to high school
kids about drunk driving I'm gonna start
um a Ministry at my church showing up
and people lose a young one I'm gonna
right that season will come that
season's not today
okay
it's not I gotta go do a thing no you
don't
okay
your body's bleeding from the inside out
and you gotta take a season to heal
going through the motions is right your
family still got to eat right you still
gotta go to work you gotta go through
the motions you gotta be busy
distraction's fine all those things are
fine until you start distracting with a
recliner and 24 7 Netflix and alcohol
and right then distractions become
unsafe but right now dude you are in
survival mode and that's fine
and anybody tells you otherwise they
probably lose your their voice in your
life for a while
is that cool
yeah
now listen to me carefully before I let
you go
you're a great dad
you're a great neighbor
and you're a great firefighter
and you lost your son and I'm sorry
[Music]
thank you
I love you Chris and anything we can do
to help you along the way let me know
okay all right and when the show's over
before I head out of here I'll send you
the link to the stuff okay
okay
sounds good thank you all right my
brother
um thank you for being brave and for
sharing your story with us and just know
there's millions of us that are
heartbroken with you all right
[Music]
thank you so much my man thank you thank
you thank you
um I don't have anything to say after
that we'll be right back
hey folks Dr John deloney here look we
live in a culture that glorifies the
grind everything's about crushing and
killing it and go go go go and we like
And subscribe and follow anyone with
tips on how to hack our way to doing
more and being more and we sacrifice
sleep at the altar of productivity and
my friends we are exhausted hustling is
well and good but burnout is real and
when you're running hard you must
remember to recharge your body with
sleep sleep is the Cornerstone to
physical and mental health and for me
getting great sleep starts with a great
mattress that's why I love dream Cloud
right now dream cloud is running an
awesome offer for our listeners 599
dollars in accessories plus an
additional 250 dollar discount that's a
total of eight hundred and forty nine
dollars in accessories and savings
you'll get pillows a mattress protector
and luxury sheets it's time to ditch
burnout culture and start prioritizing
your sleep go to dreamcloudsleep.com
deloney or dreamcloudsleep.com and enter
promo code deloni to get your new
mattress today and enjoy 849 dollars in
savings and accessories
all right we are back
um it took me a minute
I was too close to home that was tough
man be thinking about
um
him and his family I did
um I think we're quite ready for it here
but I did Spill the Beans I've signed a
um
finally talk publicly um probably one of
the most common questions I get is what
supplements I take and why and all that
kind of stuff and
um for years and years and years
um I've only used one company that I
trust when it comes to supplements and
that's thorn
t-h-o-r-n-e they're the best of the best
of the best and
I've avoided talking about them just
because there's I have there's
differences between what I think is
really important part of my daily
routine and then things that I like to
self-experiment with I just like to
figure stuff out and see what it does to
my body and then things that I feel so
strongly about I even give them to my
kids and
things anyway so I just got to stay away
from the conversation
but I realized the number of people are
going to like Walgreens and buying
things for nine dollars and they're
throwing their money away and because
the product's garbage and they also more
importantly aren't getting the help they
need
and so
um Thorn reached out and we had some
great conversations and so
um
I'll just be super upfront the way these
Partnerships work a lot of times is
[Music]
um
we get a piece I get a piece of what is
sold
but I have the opportunity to increase
the discount rate so that my pieces get
smaller and smaller the bigger your
discount gets as a listener
and right now it's more important for me
that people begin to get the help they
need real supplements are expensive they
just are they just are everybody we just
got to shake it off and say if I'm not
eating fish three to five days a week I
need to have fish oil right this is what
it is
um if I struggle with sleep and I don't
want to get on narcotics which I don't
recommend very many people do just
occasionally then there's some
supplements that can really help and
that have been a Lifeline to me so
there's several things along those lines
where my doctor has looked at my blood
work and said hey you're going to really
benefit from these three or four things
great cool
but they are expensive and so
I want you all to know that we've upped
the discount more so than you're going
to hear from most
um people in their face because I'm more
interested in I'm less interested in
making money off the deal is more
interested in getting
getting good products in the hands of
people who need them they're going to
help themselves and their family so that
I should have had a we had a bigger idea
for a product launch that wasn't planned
to tell that guy but I've been there
I've never lost my 12 year old son but
I've been struggling and I can't sleep
and it becomes a nightmare so
um we'll probably do a big fancier
launch when it comes to Thorn I'm just
glad there's a company I trust that puts
out world-class stuff and behind closed
doors they're great people too so there
we go on that all right let's go out to
uh Diane in Charlotte hey Diane what's
happening
um not a whole lot John I am really
honored to uh get to speak to you today
you too it's an honor for me to talk to
you thank you so much for for calling
and trusting me so what's up
um there's been some um issues uh within
my marriage uh I had a son as I came
into this marriage he was young at the
time
um under the age of five and
um I married my husband uh things were
good of course in the beginning
um
I don't really know where it came in but
there was some trauma that started um I
felt like some uh emotional abuse uh
towards me and my son but mainly my son
um and so we we've suffered through for
about 10 years now I I love my husband
I'm walking beside him we're separated
but I'm still walking beside him
um as he starts counseling and we try to
move forward the problem though is my
son he uh just seems to wallow in that
resentment
um and how he's been done for the last
few years and I'm trying to get him into
counseling and I just wanted your
thoughts on uh helping push him that way
because obviously right now I mean he's
he's 15 and he's you know I'm not doing
that yeah I mean I don't yeah I totally
get that I don't blame him
um
does he have a relationship with his
birth dad
he does he
does he's done with good
um healthy men relationships because I I
didn't think or I didn't feel like his
dad was going to be the father that I
wanted for him anyway but also I'm gonna
I'm gonna be mean is that okay that's
okay okay
you surrounded him with healthy men but
you also kept him in an emotionally
abusive parent such a step parent
situation for a decade
yes sir
so you get there's a mixed signal there
right I do I do
um
no there's not there's not so we're here
now
um but stepping back we have to paint a
picture of what this 15 year old boy is
has been through what what you say he's
full of resentment is he resentful at
you for leaving as he resentful for it
taking so long as you're resentful for
this old man being so
psychologically abusive to him what's he
resentful about
there what took so long what did take so
long
just understanding
um
what my position needed to be I mean I
had a child that I was Raising with him
now with him now meeting my husband and
um
I just
I don't know
it was hard
um I
I had mixed signals coming from family
um his family would say they could see
you know the differences he showed and
and the way he did but yet they couldn't
step up and say something
um because he's a man and you know he's
leading his household I guess that's I I
just called bullcrap on that they didn't
say anything because they're cowards
that's the truth
none of this leading my household
nonsense that's just garbage you can't
that's just that's just excuse for
Generations people let men just run over
their families and their kids and their
wives because of that kind of nonsense
that's just that's cowardice it's just
pure cowardice
um
laughs
so let me give you a picture of what's
in this 15 year old kid's head and I
only know because I've met with a
bajillion of them over the years okay
okay dad left him his birth dad left him
whether these are facts or not this is
what's in this 15 year old kid's head
then another man came into his life
her mom said she loved
and that guy
did everything he could to isolate him
and put him out on the side and treat
him like garbage
for a decade
and so in many ways that that Dad that
another man left him too
but I want you to I'm saying this to not
shame you I want you to try to get
inside the head of the 15 year old
because it's going to play an important
role in how we can walk out of this
thing okay
that 15 year old has been putting puzzle
pieces together for a long time whether
it's true or not and the puzzle that has
your 15 year old has put together is mom
loved that abusive stepdad more than me
yeah she cared more about that and their
new kid they had together than my safety
and my well-being
and now she wants to me to get better
because I'm not okay nah I'm not buying
that see what I'm saying yeah that's
what's in his mind right now
and more importantly than what's in his
mind that's what's in his body pulsing
through his veins through his blood
and by the way you're still sticking
with this guy
and I'm not saying it's wrong and I'm
not saying loneliness is evil and
economics issues I get it man I get it I
get it's hard
I'm just trying to to relay this picture
Through The Eyes of a 15 year old just
who's trying to navigate his world
and find out where do I fall and who is
actually on my team
that makes sense
it does
um and then he gets a chore then he's
looked at as you're the problem 15 year
old you're acting out you're not paying
attention in school you need to go get
these things
and he's like dude I'm just a kid this
world happened to me
all right yeah
here's the path forward well I I just
threw a lot at you
and maybe no one's put it that bluntly
for you before tell me what you're
feeling what you're thinking you can
tell me I'm full of crap that's gonna
hurt my feeling
no I've I've been listening to you for
quite a few years and or ever how long
and uh I felt like that's the things
that you would say
um
you didn't even have to call
I put myself uh with better help
um last year to try to navigate
this separation and
um got us into counseling last year
um we've quit the marriage counseling
um I actually quit better help and went
with the counselor that we started with
and then he's picked up my husband that
he has picked up his own counselor and
we're trying to navigate you know trying
to figure out you know how we move
forward here's how you here's there
cannot be any moving forward
until that man
comes to your 15 year old son and takes
a literal knee
and says I failed you
we could get into the psychological
abuse that sounds like a whole other
phone call but the way I talk to you the
way I isolated you the way I drank too
much around you the way I talked to your
mother
as a man that your mom brought into your
life to model what masculinity looks
like and what love looks like and what
fatherhood looks like I freaking failed
you
and I'm sorry
and then you join him
and say I let this go on too long and
I'm your mom
and if one person on the planet had to
have your best interest at heart it was
me
and I'm sorry
and everything's gonna be different from
this point forward absent that
you can do all the work you want it's
not going to compute in the mind of a 15
year old boy that feels like every
single person in his life who's supposed
to care about him bailed on him
foreign
and any sort of growth and adjustment
and therapy and all that you can talk
about it all day long either your ex or
whoever you're married to whatever your
relationship status is of this guy you
don't talk about all day long that's
fine
um that's not going to compute
it's about action it's about what are
you doing that's different
this young man has said every adult in
his life let him down
foreign
to step up and say I love you and I'm
sorry and this is what this is going to
look like moving forward and he's going
to get some years to heal
and by the way the greatest gift you can
give him after an apology is that you
heal and that your ex or separated
husband whoever heals and to get him to
quote unquote go to counseling you can't
afford them you can he's gonna sit there
and have a stare off like Good Will
Hunting you could
after you and your ex or whatever your
husband's name is you all apologize
you could say
we want to learn how to heal and we want
to learn how to say we're sorry and we
want to learn some better parenting
techniques for you we want to learn how
to love you better
would you be willing to come to these
sessions with us
so that your voice can be represented
and how we can better love you because
we have absolutely let you down and you
deserved more from that and you didn't
get it up until now
we're owning that and now we're going to
change everything
that's your invitation if he gets an I
mean that's what you do to get him to go
to counseling is you invite him to come
be a part of
helping teach you and the other guy
what love actually looks like it feels
like
but parenting actually loves and looks
and feels like
that's that's the path forward Diane
that's the path forward
love your kid enough
love your son enough
step dad if you're watching
[Music]
take all that tough guy energy and all
that
take a knee tell that 15 year old little
boy you're sorry and that this
psychological abuse ends
now
and then as I say all the time
he gonna watch you
way more than he listens to you the
proof will be not in how much therapy
you go to and how much books you read
it'll be how you treat that little boy
your move we'll be right back
it seems like everybody's talking about
how crazy the housing market is right
now and how powerless home buyers feel
mix that with the stress of moving and
life change and job change and you've
got a tornado of anxiety fueling one of
the biggest purchases you'll ever make
this is not a good idea so if you're a
new home buyer right now my advice to
you is to focus on what you can control
like the people you choose to help you
in the home buying process you need
folks like my friends at Churchill
Mortgage Churchill is a Ramsay trusted
provider that's been helping people with
their home mortgages for decades and
their home buyer Edge program will help
you skip a bunch of the stress here's
how it works apply to become a Churchill
certified home buyer and cap your
interest rate for 90 days then you'll
get a five thousand dollar seller
guarantee to help your offer stand out
so go ahead take a deep breath because
Churchill has your back check them out
at churchillmortgage.com deloney and get
the home buyer Edge today this is a paid
advertisement and MLS ID 1591 nmls
consumeraccess.org Equal Housing lender
1749 Mallory Lane Suite 100 Brentwood
Tennessee 37027 programs are for select
loan types only not available in all
states or locations
all right we're back let's take unumas
let's go to uh Ann in Sacramento what's
up man
hello
thank you for my call you got it what's
up
um I have a two adult sons they both
um have girlfriends that they've had for
long terms
both of the suns are moved out of the
home
um
girlfriends do not care for each other
[Laughter]
fix it Mom fix it and I don't want to be
the interfering person I could always
try to not not to be
um
I don't know what to do because now it
has not only it now it's filtered into
the relationship with the brothers
um when it hadn't really
um
but that's it's now come to this oh
absolutely at some point
a good girlfriend
will say you choose
family or me right and I'm being
facetious about good girlfriend
um
I'm being sarcastic of course no nobody
should ever do that it's obnoxious and
it's silly and and this is where you are
so here's here's the quick answer what
can you do literally nothing
like pragmatically nothing here's what I
would do if I was you though okay okay
so
basically you just called and said all
right
it's Fourth and 20. we're down by eight
points how do I win this game and I just
said there's pretty much no way you can
win but here's what I would try anyway
okay here's your Hail Mary pass
I would
either get in person that's the best
or get on a three-way call
or write a letter the exact same letter
to both boys
and say enough is enough is enough
as your mother I'm not willing to see
our family implode over two girlfriends
who can't get along
and yes that's very dismissive these Pro
guys probably see them as more than
their girlfriends they probably see them
as their Futures and their this is and
all the things
but the only appeal you have is to get
the brothers back in a room
are you really willing to lose your
brothership your brotherhoodness I don't
know the right word there
um
are you really willing to cash out our
family connection over this spat between
these two girlfriends
and
prepare your heart Annie because they
may pick the girl
they may pick the girl but here's the
weird thing it's your picture that blew
up not theirs
right you had this picture of the boys
are going to meet these beautiful girls
and we're gonna have these hilarious
times and me and the girls are gonna go
out we're gonna do these fun things and
we're gonna hassle the boy and that's
not happening
because for whatever reason these two
girlfriends are acting like idiots
and then your sons decided hey acting
like an idiot looks like fun we'll be
idiots too and then they joined in
I'm so sorry that your picture is just
in tatters
unfortunately I know it is
um because they were very very close
yeah
um until what happened was there a big
thing was there a big blow up or dust up
or something
um this has been gone on for several
years
and I think this the personalities
between the girls are very different
they don't mesh I don't know if there's
jealousy involved
and um oh the two brothers love each
other
oh yes they do and um
it finally came to a head I mean I we've
kind of started to notice that and this
is what I've been this lead with like
the come to a head part this is the good
gossipy part lead with this what
happened
um that's Jerry Springer this thing what
happened
the brothers decide to be silent you
know
um so we can clear this up
and instead of it getting resolved
um and you know okay the girls need to
talk you know they need to get together
they need to talk because this was their
issue you know between the two of them
and
um so the girls end up talking
I don't really know how that went I
don't think it went horrible but it
didn't completely it didn't resolve it
um
yeah things that need to be said were
said
um and then they said well
but I think then they went back to their
respective you know boyfriends and
um then the boyfriends kind of became
defensive about the things that were
said about the other person
and you know the one brother kind of
said okay I just need to take I need to
take a break from this we need there's
got to be a break from this yes
figure out how to move forward
so there's no big like like then Susie
slept with Dan and they're not like
there's none of that oh gosh no no no no
no no no no okay so it's it's like I
don't like your hair well she's annoying
she laughs too loud she doesn't even
call my birthday she didn't even follow
me on Facebook but that led to uh I'm
not going to talk to you at a party
which I can't believe she didn't I'm not
talking to her then
and then all of a sudden you wake up and
it's two years and now no one will be in
the same room together
right
it's the worst
it's the worst
I hate I'm smiling out of just sadness I
hate it for you
I hate it for you this is not supposed
to be that way people supposed to be
adults and grown-ups no I think and
maybe those girlfriends are never gonna
be best like bro down friends that's
fine they can be cordial and laugh they
can at least lie and pretend when the
family gets together for crying out loud
right you know that was that's all my my
expectation is and I thought if I
eventually needed to approach it that's
probably approach it just never gonna be
a best friend
but we have to accept each other and be
cultural at least minimally and I'll
also say this evolve it could definitely
evolve into things
that's a fantasy
and I also preach boundaries like crazy
here and if you keep going to if if a
young couple gets married and they keep
going to Thanksgiving and Mom's bananas
and Dad's always
ranting about politics and
brother and sister don't like at some
point I tell people stop going
stop going choose to be whole and yes
it's going to hurt and yes it's going to
Ricochet through everyone else's family
issues but stop going just stop and at
some level that may have happened
the only shot you've got is to reach out
to the boys I I guess you can reach out
to the girls
um you could
and just say it's hurting me I mean you
could play that card if you want but I
definitely wouldn't do that
um I'd reach out to the boys and just
say
guys I don't I just uh
I'm losing my family here and I don't
like it
Kelly's shaking her head no why not
sorry we agree don't reach out to the
girls oh I just said it's a terrible
idea yeah just out to the boys okay okay
so forget what Kelly just said for sure
when you get off this phone call the
girls both of them and say listen here
ladies I'm editing this out
don't do that Andy yeah I'll call the
boys and say I'm losing my family I
don't like it
I raised y'all better than this I raise
you to be mature raise you to love each
other raise you to have each other's
backs
mm-hmm I also raised you to be grown-ups
when people say mean things about your
girlfriend you're not in middle school
anymore I'm not going back outside meet
me at the hills at three o'clock what a
con what are we doing we're grown-ups
and just be prepared for them to pick
the girl too
it's Beau fan
at least you'll be able to sleep at
night knowing I have spoken my peace my
sons made their grown-up decisions
honestly just like I raised them to
and
now you get to grieve the holidays that
aren't going to happen and then you and
your husband get to decide what happens
next and that's hard and that's annoying
and that's not what anybody wants and
that's reality
foreign
between what we wanted and what we hoped
for and what actually happens it's just
that space
and you're having to sit in that space
and it's uncomfortable and it's not fun
but it's your space to sit in
sorry
reach out to him and let me know be bold
with them be bold
let them know how you really feel don't
hedge your bets say the words that you
want to say
be reckless in your love for them and
for your family
and then let me know how that
conversation goes
we'll be right back
so easy but most of us
undervalue real genuine relationships
our friendships our marriages we don't
know what we're doing and instead of
diving into the mess we accept
shallowness and distraction and we
wallpaper over our loneliness so let me
say this boldly you cannot be well alone
you've got to get connected to real life
people and have deep powerful
relationships I'm talking about
relationships where you can be honest
where you can open up where you can
share hard things and you each know that
you'll still show up for each other and
in my new book own your past change your
future we'll walk through a not so
complicated approach to relationships
mental health and wellness and getting
connected is a key part of that that's
why you'll learn shallowness and
loneliness are so dangerous and more
importantly you'll learn how to create
meaningful relationships in your life
moving forward there is no good app to
help adults find friendships but this
book can help go to John deloney.com to
take the next step towards Wellness
that's own your past change your future
at John deloney.com
all right we are back
um
today's song of the day is by one of my
favorite songwriters of all time his
name's Billy Joel right and if you don't
know who Billy Joel who's gotta help you
get on Spotify immediately
in fact turn this podcast off I can
start listening to Billy Joel
um
as long as a shout out to our first call
songs called lullaby good night my angel
and it goes like this
good night my angels time to close your
eyes save these questions for another
day
I think I know what you've been asking
me I think you know what I've been
trying to say
I promised I would never leave you and
you should always know wherever you may
go no matter where you are I will never
be far away good night my angel
[Music]
now it's time to sleep and still so many
things I want to say remember all the
songs You Sang for me we went sailing on
an Emerald Bay and like a boat Out on
the Ocean I'm rocking you to sleep the
water's dark and deep inside this
ancient heart
you'll always be a part of me
moms and dads hug your kids it goes
quick
we'll see you soon
[Music]